okay grifty advertising so actually
there's a step back what is a
multi-level marketing scheme
like what
because I've I've experienced a similar
thing it's like I I remember I worked at
I sold women's shoes at Sears uh and a
bank and I just remember like uh some
kind of I forgot the name of the company
but you like you can sell like knives or
whatever like that's a couple oh uh I
know what you're talking about I'm like
I'm sure there's a lot of things like
this right and I remember feeling a
similar thing like why
uh to me what was fascinating about it
is like wow like human civilization is a
interesting like a pyramid scheme like I
didn't maybe didn't know the words for
that but it's like it's cool like you
can like get in a room and you convince
each other ideas and you have these
Ambitions there's a general desire
especially when you're young to like
like life sucks right now nobody
respects you you have no money and you
want to do good and you want to be sold
this dream of like if I work hard enough
at this weird thing I can shortcut and
get to the very top yes I don't know
what that is and I also in me felt that
like life really sucks and I could do
good and I'm a lucky I I found a way to
do good I'm like and I don't know you
connect with that somehow I think
there's like this weird fire inside
people to like to make better of
themselves right I don't know if it's
just an American thing or if it but
anyway that was fascinating to me from a
human nature perspective grifter's play
on this though right like this is so the
best salesmen play on true narratives
that you already believe so the true
narrative is you know life is unfair it
is tough
um The American Dream as described by go
to a job work at the same company for 40
years and then retire to a safety net
that you're positive is going to be
there that is largely dead and so they
like play on those fears and those
problems to then sell you a pill a
solution a thing and this the problem is
is that the solution is usually worse
than even the problem they sketched out
like you will do better most of the time
by going with the regular company than
you will by going with these goofy
multi-level marketing but let me answer
your question what is a multi-level
marketing so
there's a criticism first of all that um
well let me get to what it is in theory
like at its most ideal multi-level
marketing is where you have a product
that you're selling and one of the ways
you help sell it is by rather than going
through traditional marketing like where
you go and you put out print advertising
it's like sort of a social network of
marketing I sell to you and it actually
Lex not only can I sell to you you can
then go sell this product and you'll
make money selling it and you know what
to incentivize me to get other salesmen
because when I get another salesman I'm
actually giving myself competition so
that's bad so to incentivize me to do
that they'll pay me part of what you
make right and then you go out and you
go okay well I can sell this product I
also can get new salesmen to like sell
for me and I'm gonna make money from you
whatever so it goes down the line of you
create multiple levels where you can
profit from their marketing right
the problem with this system is that
however well-intentioned it is is that
usually the emphasis of that selling and
making money ends up not being about the
product at all and ends up entirely
being about recruiting new people to
recruit new people to recruit new people
that's the real way to make money in
multi-level marketing this is where the
very true criticism of most multi-level
marketing if not all are pyramid schemes
in structure because what a pyramid
scheme is is it's all about I put in 500
and I recruit two people to put in 500
and that comes up to me and they put in
they get two people to put in 500 and it
goes to them and the reason it's a it's
a flawed business model is in order for
it to work and everyone to make money
you'd have to assume an infinite human
race and so that's not the case most
people end up getting screwed in
multi-level marketing and in pyramid
schemes that's what that is that's that
thing and the quality of the product it
doesn't necessarily matter where you're
selling to people who are financially
incentivized to like buy this thing yeah
and so you're um you're selling the
dream of becoming rich yes to the people
down in the pyramid that's the real
product of multi-level marketing
unfortunately
um and so you look at the statistics of
these companies and although they'll
make it seem like it's so easy to be the
top you know point one percent who's
making all this money the statistics are
that 97 make less than a minimum wage
doing this they spend an enormous amount
of time and just what's so cruel about
it is that's not advertised up front I
mean it's like if I go at work at
McDonald's I know what I'm getting if I
go work at Amway I have visions of
they've sold me visions of beaches and
whatever and more than likely I'm losing
money so better than 50 of people lose
money but 97 of people make less than
minimum wage it's like it's such a bad
business uh for the vast majority of
people who join it and the people at the
very top who are lying to the people at
the bottom saying they all can do it
when they can't
are making all the money so it's it's
yeah it's really messed up and the
interesting thing of of noticed maybe
myself too because I've participated in
the knife selling for like a short
amount of time that's probably the
experience that most people Cutco is it
I don't know I don't think it was Cutco
I I know what you're talking about it's
killing me but I think there are several
variations of it I think I was part of
an
um
a less popular one it doesn't like you
keep wanting to say it was called Vector
yeah yes I I something with a B was what
I was going to say it might be Vector
um yeah I get what you're saying though
it's a multi-level marketing knife
selling but the the thing is I just
remember my own small experience with it
is I was too I was embarrassed at myself
for having like participated
I think there's an embarrassment that's
why you that's why people down in the
pyramid don't like speak about it right
that your part like I don't I'm trying
to understand the aspects of human
nature that facilitate this well this is
one of the problems with fraud is
there's a tremendous embarrassment to
being had yeah also if you buy so
slightly different human nature is that
if you buy into a get rich quick scheme
and then it doesn't deliver you're more
likely to blame yourself than blame the
product for not actually working you go
well there must be something flawed with
me that's true and they constantly
reinforce this they go well it's all
about your hard work the system works
look at me I did it so if you're failing
it must be some indictment of your
character and you have to always double
down you have to dub the system can't be
flawed you must be flawed and so yeah
it's it's a really messed up system it
really preys on people's psychology to
to keep them in this Loop and that's why
in some ways these things are so viral
even though they don't actually get most
people a significant amount of wealth
and they cost most people money so it
was very unfortunate most people do have
the dream of becoming rich most young
people right and the thing is is that
everyone knows in business what do you
sell you sell solutions to problems so
if so many young people want to get rich
the product is that pitch it's you sell
them the dream why this gets so grifty
and so cruel and predatory is because
there is no easy solution to this there
is no solution that people are going to
buy
um because the real solution people want
is no work no education no skills
required no money up front and people
will pay any price for that magic pill
and people are happy to sell that magic
pill
and I think those people are very cruel
and I think deserve to get exposed for
it